what drew your attention first our that
we were talking about a bunch of things
first of all good morning to you guys
I'm sorry I'm not in Milford so I can't
get some that meet on Friday that just
that just makes you feel good about the
weekend I went to the game last night
Dan and yes it's a bit of a humble brag
but it also gave me different
perspective
look Katie was so far and away the best
player on the floor even LeBron
mentioned it really after the game and I
just don't think there's a solution for
it I'm not I I'm with you I don't think
there'll be a sweep but you know Vegas
had this had it as six and a half games
as the over-under and I said on my show
and on Collins show I thought I thought
that was an easy under bet and I'm even
more confident of it now because you you
tell me outside you mentioned LeBron and
he's really not comfortable defending
for long periods of time out in the
perimeter he's he's it like you said a
great help side guy for one possession
here or there he'll get out there but
that's not he's a powerful or center now
and Katie's playing a lot of point guard
that's just not something he's
comfortable doing and it wears him down
and there's no they have no second
option to guard him like Richard
Jefferson is their next best option but
this was 10 years ago that's a really
good option but it's not and I think
that's a huge problem and I and I think
last night showed ykb he said all year
last year he was going to be a
basketball decision
it shows what he understands his game
the difference in last night and in last
year is that when he goes by his man
Andre Robertson's guy isn't in the way
or Steven Adams guy whoever and his
Cantor's guy isn't in the way he doesn't
have non shooters and the reason he got
those he just ran right down Broadway
and dunk the basketball was Steph
Curry's on one side and Klay Thompson's
on the other and Cleveland is trained
defensively run back sprint back to the
shooters to the threes worth more than
two now the sudden Kevin Durant seven
feet tall
going downhill and nobody stopped the
ball when they did it was still too late
okay but why adjustments do you see in
Game two because you know Cleveland is
not going to roll over
they have to do something so what is it
we see in game - well the first thing
was Cleveland tried to establish Kevin
Love in the post early in the game and
he couldn't score on klay Thompson and
so I I kind of think they just go away
from that um the other problem is Kyrie
got tired
Perry was great but he ran out of gas in
the third quarter he was huffing and
puffing and he was trying to hide
defensively didn't really want the ball
offensively I mean I kind of think
they're just going to have to get more
threes out of junior get some fries out
of Kyle Korver you know the junior hit
one early but did then didn't hit any
and Kyle Korver didn't hit any I think I
think they're going to have to go to
there you know Channing fries Kyle
Korver's they're going to have to have a
game or two where they hit a lot of
threes to create more space for LeBron
the bomb was fine but you know they're
just it wasn't a lot of help there and
he was he was good but not great and
just you know he scored a lot of points
but they didn't seem too big they didn't
have the offensive weaponry to keep up
with Golden State I would say that's the
biggest adjustment is they're just going
to have to get their bench and their
shooters to get more involved in the
game because the idea of establishing
Kevin Love at times ropos it does does
Justin feel like he has the ability to
score on clay or on on Durant or on some
of those guys I remember
clay Thompson was terrible last night he
was awful and they won by 20 yeah I
can't imagine what happens with klay
Thompson get to go well they were 6 for
27 draymond Green and klay Thompson 6
for 27 but as I pointed out klay
Thompson
you know the klay Thompson and Kevin
Love are supposed to be the x-factor
here well if that's the case klay
Thompson had a horrible game and still
cancelled out Kevin Love so that doesn't
bode well for the Cavs we're talking to
Doug guy I I think they'll make draymond
beat him I think they'll put you know
they'll make dream on it about a member
in Game seven last year they were daring
dream on to shoot he had he had a bunch
of points because they weren't guarding
him say that's probably defensively the
best adjustment because you just you
can't guard Kevin Durant with one guy
he's just he's just too good and he's
like you said earlier it was a really
good point which I think you guys are
that might have got lost was you can't
waste LeBron on him because it'll gas
him and then he gives you nothing on
offense
he's Doug Gottlieb UNK sports radio the
Commissioner opened up the topic on the
heard saying you know they'd look at the
one and done here so what is a perfect
scenario for all involved or is there a
perfect scenario Doug well there's a
couple of things here first of all is a
misconception that players can't come
straight out and play professionally
they can't they've been able to go to
the d-league for years they don't and
one reason is because of salary but the
big reason is because college basketball
is the greatest promotional tool for any
of these players personal brands that
you could possibly have so it actually
exists to where you can put yourself in
a pro system for a year and then put
yourself in the draft there's been a
couple players who have been drafted out
of the D League this coming year I
believe the new CBA has greater salaries
in the dealy so I do prove you do have
an outlet for guys who want to make
money don't want to go to college I
think two and done or three and done is
perfect I do understand that the Kobe's
of the world although Kobe you remember
you were covering it Kobe was far from
ready he was awful in the playoffs and
could he have used a year of seasoning
sure it doesn't hurt the superstars but
I understand that a guy like LeBron do
you have to make and go to college we're
talking about you know one every decade
or two every decade and there are other
outlets like look the problem with the
league and when you go to the finals you
talk to some of the former players
you're like look these guys it's
Arrested Development they don't have all
the rap game they're missing things in
their games and while GM's and and
owners want want these players to be
drafted the fact is all those coaches
and owners all those coaches and GM's
get fired because they're forced to play
these kids too early they don't help you
win games and by the time they kind of
come of age they're on to a new coach in
a new GM look the the the GM's one
another year
honestly the Players Association wants
another year because this it it allows
the current players to make more money
to get more minutes the
only people that don't want the 20 year
old rule are the agents and there's a
very simple solution to it okay it's
that it's all you do is you have to
change when you're eligible for when
you're eligible for your second contract
should be based upon a certain number of
years out of high school not a certain
number of years no age if you do that
then you're not holding a guy back from
getting that second big huge contract or
do it based rated based upon number of
minutes played in the league
that's the agents are the only ones
holding us back from happening one more
item this really bothers my dance and
that's giving somebody DAP at a
free-throw whether they make or miss one
you played the game why do we need by
free class do I want to point that out
and did you get DAP from your teammates
when you when you missed your free
throws well I mean like you know the
whole thing is you have to gain you have
a free throw routine when you step back
there right by fritzy's desk and you
knock down 75 80 in a row you have a
routine you do it the same way every
time rights like Steph Curry chewing on
his mouthpiece that's part of his
routine you never screw up the routine
and so that that's what it's about it's
if you kind of go through and you'll see
guys even when they practice they'll
some of them will practice tapping guys
up so it's not close to being the most
Rich Eisen saying it's the most annoying
thing in sports and agreeing with who
was it was a polygon backbone poly poly
a wide receiver who points first down
and a meaning on you know on a five-yard
out route when they're down three
touchdowns way more annoying than
dapping up a guy but that doesn't happen
that often if they DAP after every free
throw Doug 880 times I game well the
Duke thing they're calling a defense in
calling an office there actually is a
reason so they're the only team that
cuddles up to : all pension you know
this works that's that's not other teams
don't huddle up we we added up when I
was in college well of course you're I
can't see I can't speak to look the
gapping up of not everybody some guys
don't like that like some guys are
germaphobe they don't like people to
touch it okay what's more annoying or
gapping up
at the free-throw line or Steph Curry
chewing on his mouthpiece my wife hates
Steph Curry chewing his stuff is like
she despises that she cannot she's I
can't I I don't remember who said that
was McLovin said it and she cannot take
it she's like I can't could you would
you text him and tell him like really
nice I advise it's good to hear from you
Doug I was like there on the west coast
it is beautiful I know you guys are out
here a couple weeks ago and your trip
was very well very well regarded so it's
awesome it's awesome a part of the best
lineup in sports radio
thank you but a bug but I would damp you
if you were right here nice thanks
thanks Doug and so that's Doug Gottlieb
Fox Sports Radio that would be I would
would damp him if he were here the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience